uh Dr Zaki could you also tell me
is Zak an obligation upon only those
Muslims who have to pay the zaka or is
it an obligation on all the
Muslims many of the Muslims they think
that zakat Al is only an obligation on
those Muslims who have to pay zakat this
is a misconception zakat is only F on
those Muslims who have a saving above
the level as we discussed earlier but
Zak is an obligation on every Muslim
unless he's very poor and he does not
have the provision otherwise it's
obligation on every Muslim and I beloved
Prophet mallam said it's mentioned in s
bukari volume number two in the book of
zakat Hadith number 1 153 the Beloved
Prophet malli wasallam said that give
One S of dates or Bali as Z for every
Muslim slave or free male or female
young or old that means every Muslim
whether he's free or a slave whether
he's young or he's old whether he's male
or a female they have to give Zak Zak is
an obligation on every Muslim
living but it's not required that a
person you have to give zakat for a
person who's in the womb of the mother a
fetus though there are authentic Hadith
saying that Omar be pleased with him he
had given zakat on a child which was not
born who was a Fest but that is optional
but zaka should be given on every Muslim
who's living and further it is mentioned
by beloved Prophet mm s wasallam it's
mentioned in
Al volume number four book of zakat
Hadith number 768 three the Beloved
Prophet mam said that give
zakat on the people who are under your
custody whether young or old whether
slave or free that means the person who
head of the family he gives Zak for
everyone who is under his custody
whether it be the children whether it be
the wives if the elderly people like the
father who also under the custody
looking off the father so he should give
even zakat on the father and the mother
he should give zakat on the people under
his custody of whether they are free or
whether they're slave so if he are slave
he has to give Z even for the slave so
for all the people who are under the
custody of the person it's his duty that
he should give Zak for those people so
it's obligatory on every living Muslim
unless the person is very poor or he's
very needy like a person who doesn't
have the
provision the stipulate amount for
giving Zak if he has less than that
amount then he cannot give zakat but as
Allah says in the Quran in Bak chapter
number two verse number 286 that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala does not lay on anyone
a burden greater than he can bear it's
further mentioned Surah tabun chapter
number 64 verse number 16 so fear Allah
as much as you can so if a person
doesn't have the stipulated amount if he
has half the
amount that is required to give Zak he
can even give have the amount but if it
doesn't have then it is not obligatory
on him otherwise obligatory on all the
other Muslims the Beloved Prophet M
wasallam said it's mentioned s bukari
volume number 9 Hadith number 7 to 88
the Beloved Prophet M said that whenever
I command you something do it as much as
you can do it to the best of your
ability there's a Hadith which is
mentioned in s Muslim volume number two
book of zakat Hadith number
2147 where the Beloved Prophet mm Sall
wasallam he said that there is no s for
a slave except for Zak there's no
charity for a slave except for Zak so
there are some Scholars who say that
even if the slave that you have a
non-muslim you should even give Zak for
him which is not right ruling where the
majority scholar they say it is wrong
because you should take it in context
because the clearly mentions how wasam
said it's mentioned in Abu da volume
number two book of zakat Hadith number 1
605 A beloved Prophet wasam said that
give Z for the purification of your fast
from empty talks and obscene talks and
give it to the poor Muslims So based on
this we come to know that a person
should fast he should be a Muslim so
non-muslim say if you have who does not
fast so where is the question of Zak for
him so but natural it includes that it
means only or the slaves are Muslims
this is the right ruling that you have
to give Z for the slaves which are
Muslims which you
have the answer Dr Zak